welcome to google cloud drawing board
where we doodle our way through the
cloud
today's topic what is google kubernetes
engine
this video is divided into chapters
watch the full video or skip ahead to
any section of your choice
now sam the sysadmin calls erin the
developer
her application has crashed but it
worked just fine on her workstation
they check the logs debug stuff and
eventually find
version inconsistencies the right
dependencies were missing in production
no surprise there together they perform
a risky roll back
well later install the missing
dependencies and hope nothing else
breaks
aaron and sam decide to fix the root
problem once
and for all using containers containers
decouple the os from the application
dependencies and the code
due to this abstraction sam can log into
each machine
and instruct it to run errands
containers it will pull down
just the files that have changed since
the last container
and run the new code if you need to roll
back all the old files are still there
as container images are immutable
by using containers aaron and sam solved
the
it worked on my machine problem
containers help
improve portability shareability
deployment speed
reusability and more turns out sam's
responsible for more developers than
just
aaron with large number of developers
containerizing their apps
sam needs a better way to orchestrate
all the containers that these developers
are shipping
solution kubernetes kubernetes is a
portable
extensible open source platform for
managing containerized workloads and
services
but turns out kubernetes is not that
simple to manage from installation to
provisioning to upgrades
slas and scaling so sam looks into
google kubernetes engine gke is a
managed service for running kubernetes
apart from making it easy for you to
create clusters it offers some
advanced cluster management features
including load balancing
auto scaling auto upgrades auto repairs
logging monitoring and more
now how does gke work all kubernetes
objects in your containerized app
run on top of a cluster which is the
foundation of gke
cluster consists of at least one control
plane and one or more machines called
nodes which are created during the
cluster creation process
the control plane includes the
kubernetes api server
scheduler storage and core resource
controllers
the control pane is responsible for
deciding what runs on all the clusters
nodes
this can include scheduling workloads
managing networks storage
life cycles scaling and upgrades
now the nodes a node runs the services
necessary to support the containers that
make up your clusters workloads
these include the container runtime and
the kubernetes node agent
cubelet which communicates with the
control plane and is responsible
for starting and running containers
scheduled on that
note pods are the smallest most basic
deployable objects in kubernetes and
contain
one or more containers pods also contain
shared networking and storage resources
for their containers
now how do you use gae we know that gke
works with containerized apps so before
you deploy a workload on gke cluster you
must first
package it into a container to create a
continuous integration and continuous
delivery pipeline
you can use cloud code to write your
apps send the code to a source code
repository which kicks off
a build process in cloud build leading
to container images which can then be
stored in container registry
ready to be deployed in gke you can then
create the gke cluster using
cloud console ui gcloud command line
interface
or the api cube ctl cli comes
pre-installed in cloud shell to run
commands against your kubernetes
clusters
availability and scaling for
availability you can choose between two
types of clusters
zonal and regional regional clusters are
better suited for aj because they have
multiple control planes across multiple
zones in a region
while zonal clusters have one control
plane in a single zone
this also means that changes to cluster
config
takes longer in a regional cluster
because they must propagate across all
control planes
due to these tradeoffs choose regional
clusters when availability is more
important than flexibility
and choose zonal cluster to create or
upgrade clusters rapidly
when availability is less of a concern
gke also provides
four types of auto scaling for workloads
and infrastructure
horizontal pod auto scaler for adding
and removing parts based on utilization
metrics like cpu
and memory vertical part auto scaler for
sizing your pods
cluster auto scaler for adding and
removing nodes based on the scheduled
workload
node auto provisioning for dynamically
creating new node pools with nodes that
match the needs of your user's pods
how to secure your app using gke gke
is secured by default with automatic
data encryption at rest and in transit
the os images you deploy are google
certified
you can access your clusters without
public ip
on the internet and you can control
access using identity and access
management
and role-based access controls
additionally with gke you get trusted
networking
using global vpc you can connect to and
isolate clusters
using global load balancing you can
deploy public services behind
a single global anycast ib using cloud
armor
you get easy protection against layer 7
and ddos attacks
and using networking policies you can
control the communication between your
cluster pods
gke also comes with tools to verify
enforce and improve the security of your
infrastructure
you get binary authorization to ensure
only properly signed containers are
deployed to production
vulnerability scanning of the container
images
finds security vulnerabilities early on
in the ci cd pipeline
and since the base images are managed
they are automatically patched and
updated for security vulnerabilities
with all that said if you are looking to
quickly start with containers
check out gke at cloud.google.com
kubernetes engine